everybody and welcome to another Python
tutorial series this series can be
dedicated to pandas so if you're not
already familiar with pandas pandas is
basically a it's like a module that
combines a lot of other modules and
brings a little bit of its own stuff to
the table to make data analysis data
manipulation and also data visualization
really quick and easy so that's we're
going to have a series on if you've been
following some of my other tutorials I
did have a Python pandas with sentiment
analysis that's more like an applied
tutorial video series with pandas if
you're just looking for the pandas
basics and you want to do your own thing
with pandas you just want to learn a
little bit about pandas this will be the
series for you so anyway with that let's
go ahead and get started and I'll show
you guys how to get pandas and all of
that so if you go to pandas their
website or how to get pandas is going to
be pandas PI data org and when you get
there this is probably something similar
to what you will see you'll probably
want to click on get pandas and then if
you come down here you can get
everything on the pi PI website you can
also go to this guy's website here which
I have already in a tab and then you can
also get the source tarball from github
so here is where on pi PI you can come
down here and you can get you know the
source you can also get it downloadable
as well and then also if we go to their
github you can get the source and then
finally this is the website that they
had suggested I like using this website
it's a bunch of windows installers so if
you're on Windows this is really simple
you're not on Windows then sorry oh
you'll have to get it I'll probably just
get it from other pi PI page personally
but when you do get it or wherever you
go you have to understand that you need
a bunch of modules so let me do
pandas and we'll find pandas when you
come down here you can see that it
requires numpad 8 util and PI T Z so
you're going to need to download all of
those I would just hold down your
control key and click click click if you
don't already have them the next thing
that we're going to want
I don't think we'll use Sai PI in this
see
but if you don't have a sci-fi you might
as well get it people use it a lot Matt
plot live we will use you'd want to pull
that one up and that should be it if
this is your first real series that
you've ever done with Python a lot of
people get Python just to use pandas
there might be some other things you
need eight utils is here trying to think
of some of the other ones that people
bring up all the time they need names
are all evading me but if when you go to
install pandas or import pandas at the
end and you have a problem just leave a
comment and I'll help you all out so
anyways download this install pandas and
make sure you install for sure numpy
date until pi TZ and Matt plot live and
if you're want to go ahead and grab
these other things these are all pretty
good ones I've never used SQL alchemy
but I've used Sai PI bottleneck don't
think I've ever used this numb expert
but anyway so get those and went on when
you're done downloading or when you
think you're all done downloading open
up you know the Python interpreter here
and do import pandas and if you can
import pandas then you did it right if
you get an error you did something wrong
if you can't figure it out again just
leave a comment below and I'm probably
able to help you out chances are you
just missing an import or something and
you'll probably see it even when you do
the install or when you do import pandas
it'll say specifically no module named
and if you don't have that module what
you should do if you're especially on
your window if you're on Windows come to
this website and just search for either
in this big chunk of text it's in
alphabetical order or just use ctrl F
and search for you know like say you
want to numpy man it went all the way to
the bottom but we had none PI here yeah
you can get numpy here as well you click
it come down here and you can download
what you need so when you're all done
you should be able to import pandas and
then you be ready to program with us in
the next video so anyway again if you
have any questions or comments feel free
to leave those in the section below as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support of subscriptions and
until next time